let's get to the next and final question
pail tourists where'd you go Jim oh I'm
sorry
where you going I'm not going anywhere
come on back you this is the least
professional thing we've ever done
the least professional we are both
trained professionals masters of our
craft and look at you you're just moving
your head around pocket pull yourself
together we're gonna get through this
yes I want to make sure I mention pale
tourists you do stand-up in other
countries obviously not possible now
during this time of co vid but you and I
both love doing that going to other
countries doing comedy exploring the
people in the culture I probably know
that we're more sensitivity and and
layered nuanced but you go there and do
whatever it is you do are you enjoying
it I love it I wanted to call my show
gym Without Borders mm-hmm but people
were like that's too similar to Doctors
Without Borders no I I do love doing it
you know I mean it's like ah you know
mine I just do stand-up because I you
know I don't need to be propped up by a
group of other people I just do it
myself but I it's a scary assignment
right and I'd love to know what you
think that'd sound believable right but
no I would it was fun and I and I'm
disappointed because I was gonna do
Latin America yeah and then the
coronavirus head we've all been
sidelined but you are doing a great job
I mean between most-wanted and of course
the pale tourists why don't I tell
people where they can find those most
one is gonna be in theaters and on
demand friday in theaters how's it going
to be in theaters I don't know it says
it says in theaters I think it is well
it's I think they play it in a movie
theater and people sit in the theater
and they watch it okay that would know
what makes sense most wanted in theaters
and on demand
Friday and the pale tourists where you
see Jim go and do stand-up brilliant
without borders but like with you know
meek you know will be available on
Amazon Prime video on Friday Jim um I
did my best you know I I gave you the
benefit of the doubt I extended the hand
of friendship and you swot white what do
you got you got something
eczema but no it has been so great
talking to you Conan thank you for
having me
our final interview my final interview
with with Jim Gaffigan you see the way
pill force I've been posting them on
YouTube okay people not monetizing it no
monetize monetize away you live in a
house again I'm tired of seeing you in a
restaurant get out I want you to get out
and get a house okay you've got 65
mouths to feed
Jim I care about you I hope your lawsuit
with John Malkovich goes well um and I
wish you all the best
you really are very funny sometimes
petulant and cruel person but you're one
of my top 600 favorite comedians that's
pretty good of the late 90s yeah thank
you Jim Gaffigan I salute you thank you
thank you so much you're good magic okay